io is with us in New York hey Kyle how
are you good how are you better than I
deserve what's up okay so I just
question the chat already and I've
listened to your show for the past few
months not one not to work and I have a
question for you about student loan debt
so I have around $25,000 or so on that
and some two point five two point three
thousand in credit card so my question
is should I use I'm gonna be moving to
another city in Midwest which is cheaper
to New York City
in July and I was doing some
calculations and if it works really hard
and like really cook much my costs in
twelve months I can pay off all my debt
yeah well somebody who's punished Weiser
who graduate from high school actually
he works with that and he's being the
advice he said told me two things one I
should instead of like paying off on
that quicker I should invest that money
maybe even index funds because an idiot
rate this cousin it is you only take
advice from him right right so because
in my head a in debt and invest your
money
that's an idiot okay stay away from
people that say stuff like that because
the best way to become wealthy Keio is
to not have any payments your most
powerful wealth building tool is not
borrowed student loan money your most
powerful wealth building tool is your
income and right now you're smothered in
debt and you know you spent half your
life looking at this dadgum debt
payments so now this guy just graduate
from college yeah I got socks older than
him you don't want to listen to that
stuff man that's just stupid stuff now
make your move
get out of debt your plan works do your
plan it's what you're it's what your
heart was telling you to start with
until somebody tried to tell you you
weren't sophisticated well you are
sophisticated he's a young immature and
stupid
don't follow that plan bad plan hope I
wasn't unclear hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
down
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh